hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Cola we have to get
going because we are immediately in the
thick of the [ __ ] that is death oh hey
death how you going I was just talking
about you
Oh remember how I didn't remember that
you were behind me wasn't that great
times back then how about you not do the
hi I'm gonna get adilyn
I'm skedaddling I'm askin at least good
and ler okay so he is still behind me or
it was a new guy and this whole place is
a no it was a new guy I did not notice
the new guy okay so I need to be kind of
quick about this in kind of mindful it
is very hard to see these guys down in
the depths of hell that I'm an
apparently someone over there easy prey
by me okay relatively okay now back to
wondering what the hell happened here
seriously like boys this all on fire
what could possibly lose that okay I
hear him behind me do i I don't know if
I do
hello page can I have you can I have you
inside my journal said we got a beer yes
please over here yes yes yes yes no yes
no yes thank you
I stopped read for a bed to the pass
thank God we made it yeah on our way I
felt someone was following us I heard
strange whispers around I sometimes even
caught a glimpse of a moving shadow in
the trees yeah there were moments I
could feel someone's breath upon my
shoulder hmm but when I stopped still
hearing the snow crunching under ones
boots
hey turned around there was nobody there
I had the impression this is a place of
some horrid altar of madness problem
nothing is as it should be yep or it's
some kind of a nightmare
yeah calling that and then we found the
bodies good something told me not to
look but it looked like something was
sticking out or maybe there was just
some voice in my head which kept
repeating go down there go I can hear it
clearly even now so I went down and
found the remaining four
the way they looked what on earth could
have happened to them
I'm not able to describe it in detail
smashed skulls twisted limbs broken ribs
torn cut or burnt skin never ever have I
seen anything like this a gruesome image
of madness or some sick experiment as if
someone or something played with them
and abandoned the destroyed toys in the
forest
I felt madness were slowly but firmly
overcoming my soul you're not crazy I'm
crazy we're all crazy here and it's
apparently aliens but that's not crazy
to say it's out life happening someone
life happened oh good totem pole of
faces I love that that's good I'm gonna
get out of here now this place literally
hell literally hell think I saw Hitler
down the way get out of what am I like
oh no oh no Mike okay all right I just
had to duck a little bit that is really
pretty
I will admit this game is very pretty
that is a very scenic overlook but I
want to get the hell out of here I wanna
get the hell out of hell okay so where
was that on my map so oh that was the
forest I didn't even know there was
another one over there
I just happen to stumble across that
here
all right okay what is that over there
Wow that's the thing is that another
campsite or is that the same campsite
not entirely sure pretty sure that's a
new one so I'm gonna go towards there
just in case I'll have a safe point then
I may be able to okay that's glow excuse
you forest of demons please don't do
that and why did you do that
it looks so peaceful and serene from a
distance it's oddly really beautiful
like I gotta admit it's gorgeous I mean
obviously a lot of the things in this
game are repetitive like it's it's kind
of all the same in terms of textures and
what's going on in the game but god it's
pretty it's well done well made I don't
even know what engine this is on okay
yeah okay we got it we got it got it
you're in it hello thank you I'm gonna
save and apparently I'm right here so
the next place I need to go 5461
fifty-four yeah I guess I might as well
just keep following the path are you
looking okay so what I just got to do is
got to keep following the path there
quicker no okay I'm just gonna make a
big loop around the whole place and hit
a whole bunch of landmarks on the way
there
I'll keep an eye on you fiery bastards
out here you burn now this forest
nature's Majesty or some I don't care
just don't kill me burn all the trees
you want or don't I don't I'm not an
environmentalist okay I gotta admit also
the noise the noise that's pumping into
my ears the music and the sounds really
really good god is so good it's really
immersive too because I kind of feel
like I'm here let me actually turn it up
in my ear holes get all that yeah that
rich snow blowing in my face and almost
feel the cold biting my bones wait where
was the path that was poised at the path
okay alright Fran jumps loading up
something significant all right cool
I think this is the right way to go
pretty sure one-way path oh so I
couldn't have so I wouldn't have even
been able to get over there so I should
be able to take left turns out of your
room
another page oh it's just a bountiful
day four pages who's gonna give me what
who's gonna tell me what next story of
craziness is going on here I really do
wonder if like I was supposed to take
the all brief oh gods confessions 72
year-old Anna and after years of silence
decided to talk about events from a past
she told us
I am terminally ill and have nothing to
lose and those weird noises I shouldn't
bother with those and that thing mind
you you shouldn't worry about that I
want people to know that what harm has
been done I've been done all of us in
the name of science and and describe the
place
sighs Research Center we're scientists
allegedly conducted human human
experiments on predator there was a
special chamber they had never allowed
us to even get close it was guarded by
soldiers although I did see people that
were taking their nominee came back I
kept in touch with one of them I asked
what they've been doing in there and why
so few come back out of there live he
looked at me terrified he said Anna have
you ever seen nothingness a deep
emptiness with no end I was there I
stood above the collapsed Valley of the
universe on the border between reality
and unreality
there's an abyss there a gigantic well
with no bottom a dark cave of Hell and I
felt it it was drilling into my head
like a ticking clock it looked at me
from below it was sneaking up on me and
slowly started entering me the darkness
some time later the same prisoner gave
me a letter to pass on in which he had
begged for help I was supposed to give
it to the press and expose the whole
thing but the letter disappeared up
until now I don't know what happened
anyway they would probably cover up the
whole thing we asked the supervisors of
prison unit 2 which Anna Anne was
subject to for a comment
Wladimir chrome ski the unit's commander
strongly denied such events took place
he also informed us in short message
that Anna Anne was guard but never
worked in - mentioned above center
because of an object like that simply
doesn't exist
he said Anna Anne's employees record as
proof that in years 1940 to 1950 she
worked in Tsuchinoko prison also known
as special object number 110 she hadn't
been let go from this facility due to
mental illness a copy of her health
record well those could have been
fabricated but who wrote this seriously
who wrote this where did this come from
what why was this note here that
explains a little bit of woe
going on but not enough okay let's find
out where okay yeah so I'm in the right
place I just need to follow this down
and then I'll be going into the pit of
hell which apparently is exactly where I
wanna go
Windsor is whipping up a storm over here
are those noises I should be worried
about I really do wonder if the not
wolves that I'm hearing I should worry
about
oh boy Christmas trees is it that time
already let me go bow to my shrine to
Santa okay
Shanna doesn't like to be mentioned it's
the Santa from Futurama that comes
around here
okay 69 71 that that would be helpful
buddy what is that like high-pitched
ringing
all right either way okay moving on I
already know where I am I just need to
follow it until something big and mad I
was about to say comes in my face but
it's not what I'm in don't misinterpret
me don't mix up my words even though I
said it in that exact way no you stop
stop that now stop that comes up to my
face that's what I meant
so let's just go with that one and
ignore it - unison Apple oh is that it
is it dull yellow glow in the sound of a
room on the sound of a rustling page us
friendly Oh super
slept in something you could call a
hotel I won't two persons per bed Tinky
woke up at 9 a.m. that's actually quite
comfortable although it was a little
cold because we forgot to close the
window vent you didn't huddle packed our
things and at 11 a.m. we were ready to
go we set off in the back of a truck so
it was a bit cold during the ride we
talked about absolutely everything we
could think of you've been doing a lot
darker now we spoke with some local
workers I remembered one in particular
he had a red beard or so friends called
him beard man Oh clever we cooked and
ate dinner and now we are resting ready
don't ever agree to coconuts and maps
the rest are sleeping I started handling
the equipment in writing it is still a
bit too cold my hands are shaking but
finally my thoughts are much brighter
than yesterday
no creepiness in them whatsoever there's
a long way ahead of us but the only
thing I can feel is excitement it seems
as if the forest is calling us that
beautiful magical dark forest burned
down one over there yeah it was already
like that when I got there no dead
bodies either okay that's the ambiance
but oh this dark force oh this one the
one that's dark what the hell is that
who the hell's you why the hell am I
here what the hell is going on why am i
shouting
okay this this is definitely a dark
forest but I don't know about magical
horrifying death-defying oh good my
flashlights blinking I was hoping that
happened he always goes to sting it was
there's too comfortable air aah
why the [ __ ] out good
Oh God trees I'm stuck I'm too fat ah
okay get the noise I did the sound
actually go out there was that just me
in my ears okay well guess I'm now I'm
here now I'm just gonna forget all the
troubles that I just experienced I'm
gonna let my guard down this is why we
fear the darkness oh god I hear a page
why do I have to go for the page it's so
stupid
haters are stupid they're you're you
glowy evil page oh the Sylvian research
unit for natural phenomena regarding the
occurrence anomaly Oh H - nine one first
incidence took place between 1950 and
1953 in the Aria of Agartha by the
construction of the trans polar mainline
the works were halted in the incidents
classified any witnesses were ordered to
be eliminated on October 17 1950
according to witness evidence at the
same altitude as camp 503 to the west of
in darkest city an emanation of unknown
force and sound a curtain caused instant
death of 42 workers the bodies literally
evaporated no more shadows were left
great I think I found them as the
witnesses testified the incident was
sudden in short the next incident took
place
three years later on March 14th 1950
shut up you [ __ ] then also in the
above-mentioned camp of solidification
effect occurred the bodies of 12 worker
just froze after all I didn't know they
could get me oh come on man oh I didn't
know it was all real [ __ ] what's all
I thought I was safe I thought I was
safe
I was not safe Oh am I at the same place
I was Oh God all the horrors oh they're
all real okay I got to go up oh crap did
I just yeah excuse me I gotta go up
because I need to get around so that I
can actually get in the house it's
probably not where I wanted to be all
right cool that's good enough I guess
all right cool great can I go this way
please another page of rustling
somewhere oh this lips secure
Chris page there it's down there oh it's
probably down there well if that's the
case I'll come back for it cuz I think I
think this is just the weight of the
cabin here yeah sure we're tanning all
the hides but I haven't seen any animals
anywhere
I don't think animals exist around here
I don't think any life exists around
here
cept for me cuz I'm awesome Oh
Dingaan Girl Scout cookies ha [ __ ] you
I'm out of thin mints
alright okay thanks I'm so polite always
closing the door behind me thankfully
that knife has been turned into an arrow
and it's pointing up ready then I don't
know if they can get me in here oh hey
hi hello hi okay bye don't leave me
so I'm coming in after me the Sun is
just starting to set I see it like I am
there myself
hey as if I'm standing there in the
middle of the forest yep I'm not sure
what is going on with reality I'm
writing with my own blood on a tree no
you're reading on at my own named Anton
no not mine
his the Sun is just starting to set
orange mist orange mist all around I I
see their bodies coming out of the woods
mm-hmm I her scream yeah horrific scream
of terror yours my voice I think it is
where's Anton where did he come from
how did he get in it the Sun is just
starting to set he's in me he's
he's coming in through my eyes the eyes
are windows to the soul
yes oh where is Anton I don't know I'm
dropping in a bottomless abyss falling
into the path dead and rotting hands
catching me on my way down I can feel
them whisper into my ear now you are
ours you will never leave us
I'm calling him I'm calling Anton where
is that Todd I don't know I see nothing
my eyes overflowing with blood risky
doctor run away I have to start running
it's just starting wait so what's gonna
happen Teddy Teddy Teddy Teddy let me in
let in
come on
am i safe gutbucket I'm not safe
okay I'm going going you smell bad I'm
nowhere and everywhere and out there
especially
okay I think that's enough for this
episode thank you all so much for
watching I'm gonna go have nightmares
now hope you really are enjoying the
series it's really good it's like really
good hot damn
holy hell where did he come from when
did he go where the hell is Anton thanks
again everybody for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video